out from the universe light enters two
little balls in my head and reveals the
intricate display of the life around me
the clump of paste that calls itself my
brain refers to a bank of memories and
integrates this moment into a story a
story that only I have experienced and a
story that only I will ever experience
for the first time today I am reminded
that I am alive that today I get to
experience the incredible phenomenon
that is this life unlike anything else
known in the galaxy I am on a planet
with the perfect conditions and
resources to allow for the possibility
of life unlike anything else ever known
on this planet I'm experiencing a state
of consciousness that is lucid enough to
be self-aware of its own existence and
like any time ever before there is
technology so powerful that I can see
the experience and connect with this
entire planet right now today I can
choose what I want to do with all of
this I can choose to see the beautiful
fascinating and/or inspiring side of it
all the love the infinite possibility in
the unknown the opportunity to play on
the playground that is life
because today right now against all the
odds somehow I am awake and not only
that against even greater odds somehow I
am aware than I am awake today I can
realize that I have today and today I
can be thankful for that
and make the absolute most of it
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder